we get approached about everything
almost and I think there's a there's a
place for that I'm not sure the timing
is right I think that we have a
wonderful brand with an enormous amount
of brand equity and that's something you
need to spend wisely and it's very easy
when every day you open your email and
is 5 get-rich-quick schemes coming at
you and some of them are appropriate but
I think that it's very easy to lose that
iconic nature by exploiting it and I
think when going this might not this is
pertains to this but it's something that
will you'll get a minute when i took
Magnolia from the hole in the wall and
it was all it's a whole wall on bleecker
street and said ok how we can enroll
this brand out you can't go build on the
walls and if you want to have ultimately
a sale in equity sale or go public no
one's buying into a concept that's that
deconstructed so we had to take the
elements of magnolia and what makes it
famous and what makes it important and
what makes it resonate with people and
move it to the next level and what we
found one of the things we were very
careful about when brands have an iconic
status there's a shared perception of
ownership by the public and it's very
easy to lose that trust because people
think really think they ever position in
it and it'd be like fighting with your
sibling and getting into one of those
crazy fights where no one talks at the
holiday dinners anymore with your
clientele we didn't want to be in that
position so we were very very careful to
deconstruct what we thought were the
elements that made magnolia magnolia and
take it to the next level and that same
trust and iconic nature and ownership
still exists it's actually growing so
it's very easy to exploit that I can
take that trust and oh and sell other
products I can take that trust and go
into a grocery store but
I think that's diluting the brand equity
at this point I think that we need to be
a stronger brand I think we're very
clear of who we are but we need to
strengthen that in the perception of who
we are now twill we stand for in the
marketplace and I think there will be
opportunities to exploit that without
the bad connotation of that word whether
that's a certain amount of organic
merchandise growth where we're going to
expand the t-shirt line and hats mugs
obviously there are ways we can come
into your home if we want through the
kitchen with some product and we can
certainly put product in grocery stores
the problem on some level though is a
large part of our cash a enormous amount
of who we are is small batches made
fresh daily we use an old-fashioned cake
recipe that doesn't use oil so we are
constantly working on the problem that's
attended with that which is bread
products and cakes drive very fast in
the air if you put stabilizes in them
and oils and other tricks you can keep
them with two a three days shelf-life
moist we don't have that luxury because
we're skewering to a specific time date
and recipe so unless we want to
compromise that you can't take that
product and put it into a grocery store
because eight hours later the products
already using its shelf life we're
donating it to the homeless shelter
around the street of course the street
so you're not getting that but in a
grocery store how do you do that so
that's so taking our most iconic product
we can we can't do that one but what we
are working on there are ways to
flash-freeze and to ship and maybe
they'll be ways down the road to
flash-freeze and keep them frozen but of
course we've got to make sure the taste
is the same so we're working on that now
wait on the jury's out we think that so
far our taste tests have shown us that
we could get ninety-eight percent of the
way there and yet the two percent is
only the people that make it needed
le and work with it but no so it's very
encouraging but there are other products
that over time we might want to do that
with a natural for us would be a
magnolia bakery cupcake mix and there
are other people that have shops
throughout the country that are doing
that we could easily do that and that is
something that might come onto our radar
shortly